the Joe Rogan experience I understand
but the little home with nothing to do
right now and then they're firing into
writing articles like this is a gendered
crisis well Bill Maher went hard to
paint dead and he was right he was right
yeah he was also not totally right cuz
he was defending the use of the term
Chinese virus but really correctly
termed it would be the Wuhan virus yeah
but everyone know right right everyone
knows that it originated in China yes
but if but if we called it the Wuhan
virus it would be historically accurate
right because racists we're gonna do
hate crimes wouldn't know if Wu hen was
in China like they would be like is ill
that's what I'm saying you're
generalizing an entire continent or okay
an entire country enormous country it's
just a subset a small section of it that
had the virus well it's like the
examples they used was like Lyme disease
came from Lyme Connecticut but if
something came out of Colorado and it
was killing everybody just Rocky
Mountain ticks would they say in China
they call it that in China would they
say the US flu the American bug I don't
know I mean someone in Chinese I mean
there's day it's a way to generalize it
it's sloppy but listen this is the way
it's been done for years yeah but
there's a clear reason why look Trump
first of all they were in heated trade
negotiations with China right so he
wants to rub it in their face China
China yeah hang and he also wants to
take attention away from the fact that
we were not prepared and really knew and
everyone knew not only him Nancy Pelosi
all of these people all even foul Chi
all of these guys came out and said this
is nothing to worry about but Trump is
the president the buck stops with him he
could have ordered tests he could have
been more vigilant he didn't do it so I
think well they were all saying not to
worry about it everyone the World Health
Organization yeah January in January
they were saying it does not transmit
from person to person yeah but if you
listen if you're skeptical of China and
you're skeptical the W the World Health
Organization as he's very skeptical
China well you got a yeah the World
Health Organization up until then had
not been criticized the way it's been
criticized now of course but you still
have to I think if you're the Pres
you're in a leadership position you have
to be like wait a minute what are we not
knowing the CIA wrote him a memo saying
this could be a big problem yeah I mean
we knew we were watching it happen for
two months in another country we're
watching this happen in China and I'm
not saying that he could have prevented
the pandemic but like dude get the tests
give him the New York give him a certain
big area so you know have the scale up
the testing so what do you think I
didn't scale up the test I don't think
he's guilty no he didn't scale up the
test I don't know if it's first of all
is it him but who is he the one who
doesn't he's the president he said what
yeah how do you even know like when you
say he should have yes but I didn't know
what was possible yeah well first of all
you could have the defense production
Act which I don't think he could have
invoked that after this happened had to
force companies to make certain things
right but there was a lot of people that
were thinking that this was just gonna
be like the flu if the president the
United States said we need more tests
for this there's absolute absolutely we
would have had more tests but do you
understand they didn't even have a test
yes it's a novel coronavirus
there's a new thing yeah but there were
tests in other countries were being used
I mean Germany did this right what does
it do they had more testing they've had
a mortality rates they've had to cap the
mortality rates down they think there's
a bunch of reasons why Germany kept
their mortality rates a very you know
the culture but but here's the other
thing if you have a rules better Taiwan
did it South Korea I mean now they're
having second waves but like up until
recently I wanted very few cases just
right by China but again a lot of it was
testing so I mean I think the China
virus issue helps him deflect from any
and I mean listen you you can't go out
during a pandemic when nurses wearing
garbage bags and falling down to go hey
my press conferences are getting the
biggest ratings that was the dumbest
thing I can't do that and that's crazy
no that was just that's crazy but that's
him he's a yeah [ __ ] weird guy yeah
but he also did shut down travel from
China that was good
he's more saying he was a racist well
that yeah well Chuck Schumer should be
held to account for that yeah yeah they
really should because that was the
correct thing to do I don't think you
could have prevented this I'm just
saying there's got to be a better system
than the one we have where states are
like bidding for this equipment like
there's got to be a way
and that $1,200 stimulus that people get
aget is not helping anybody know this
one but when you say states are
what are you talking about I mean states
are I don't think the federal government
has the ability or we don't have the
ability to get States equipment so stage
like bidding for it there's something
going on with like a lot of states are
going outside the systems like secure
there which part part of their
responsibility is to do but it's just
there's got to be a better system going
forward yeah well they didn't see this
coming
I mean in terms of needing ventilators
like you go back to November or December
nobody thought that three months from
now the entire country is gonna be shut
down we're gonna need ventilators
everywhere no of course not and we and
and and some hospitals may not need
ventilators we got a look at a city like
New York and you got to look at what's
happening in China and you got to go
there's a high population density there
we should probably try to shore up some
of those hospitals you know I mean
otherwise what the hell does you know
but a lot of people who run the
hospitals the administration of the
hospitals isn't their responsibility to
make sure that they have PPE in place
the fact these people were in garbage
bags they don't have enough mass well I
don't think any hospital is prepared for
a pandemic so if you're I don't think
well I mean the gospel I think certain
people have to direct them to do that
right but when you're talking about just
masks how the [ __ ] don't they have a
large supply of masks on that it's not
that I don't actually prohibitive I mean
that I don't know I have no idea but
they know no but there's got to be some
there's got to be some responsibilities
you know either it might be state
government it could be local government
but there's got to be some
responsibility somebody [ __ ] up
somebody [ __ ] up
[Applause]